oh you're in charge now yeah i started i
knows you know what I'm gonna be the bad
you want to do a show yeah I want to do
is show you want to do it we'll do a
show how's that let's do a show see I
took it back Hollywood a chase why honey
wanna Jason Hollywood a jason AKA
nowhere near hollywood but closer than
welcome to Hollywood anonymous i
embroider when I'm John Huck all right
yeah so I did it feel good to do your
own enjoy the Sun remember one used to
be I used to ask you to riff we're back
in the day yeah well we tried to we try
to do songs about I would try to make up
lyrics but I can't now on the side thing
even though it is my thing in every
other moment of my life woody game I
can't like if you could talk to Nicole
she like all I do is sing random
nonsense do you sing / songs and people
are trying to listen to like in the car
does it annoy her not all the time but
sometimes then yes I do it to the kids
all time well that's it because it shut
up but that's because you're just trying
to annoy them but I mean you're just
trying to sing over there nonsensical
crappy pop kid music I with their names
in every song or an animal name of ya
house in the soldier and they never say
like can I just listen to the song
because they got us fun that's why did
your kids know about weird al yet oh why
not why what do you mean because it's
great I'm not again this is not this is
not a platform to define with the
greatness of weird al yankovic I'm just
I don't know why that had be no platform
he's great that's it there's no plaque
I'm sure he is funny but then again it's
like would they understand half the
stuff that he's talking about yeah well
especially his newer stuff that makes
fun of the music that they listen to
he's still doing stuff be yeah yeah and
in it yeah he just want to Grammy don't
don't okay first off do not make fun of
you I've happened earlier we are one
woman right okay but also the time to
enjoy him is when while you're young
well everybody our guests yet wait I'm
Perkins I wasn't sure I this works
comedian no you're right we should have
told you we should have told you you
don't talk until the last five minutes
in a wee bit yeah yeah yeah we actually
just love whatever crap you have and
then you just leave right right we call
you a guest no they're called observers
we're going to observe our show you
wanna come over watch us do a podcast
oh yeah yeah what time to be there I
have actually does a podcast where it
was so hard to actually be a part of the
conversation that you almost said
yourself what why was I right yeah
because you know and it's tough i get
that like if you have like a show and
you have this dialogue that you want to
have but you also want somebody else in
how do you get them in but we just
decided like we're just gonna ask you
questions then you're in but right right
to say to somebody hey man it's up to
you if you got a you know you gotta
fight your your your point of view and
it's like well I didn't know this was
supposed to be if no no you were fine I
think that happens when you have like
multiple like we have 15 people on the
show today your and it's like everyone's
vying for time but like the purpose of
this show is to talk to Dwayne and like
only Duane will took this long enough
every episode is supposed to be just
Duane those other 30 no one talked about
you and the other seven so we try that's
upsetting yeah what I calling you you
didn't write those other episodes were
practice runs for when doing finally
made it this is a final episode right
that sounds like something you say girl
like every other girl was just a
practice name yeah you I don't and I
still burn it off god damn it do you
seriously think one would appreciate
that comment of course you just got to
keep that number law you can't be like
the thoughts another girl asks 2733
chicks I've [ __ ] have all been leading
up to you yeah you gotta keep that
number is herpes um this sore yeah this
is all for you uh Duane accomplished
comedian writer and now I would we say
filmmaker carpal tunnel survivor uh I
read in a book I read this book called
polar how to write screenplays for
profit I think the guys your mom yeah
Thomas you know a 911 wrote it yeah yeah
and uh there's a part where they say
like you're not right if you don't have
carpal tunnel you're not writing enough
and I actually had a carpal tunnel brace
that made me feel so you're like to show
you guys really actually have pumping it
out you just got it because I want to
make the feeling I'm opposing yeah I
gotta be if I'm gonna be a screenwriter
I got to have the carp tons yeah every
time you're at Starbucks every morning
all this writing for success can you
just hold the cup for me while I drink
from it cuz my carpal tunnel is acting
up do you guys have carpal tunnel straws
does it is does that act uppers are
always painful
uh you know what it is uh it only went
when I type and it helps if I way it
while I sleep oh I find its if I sleep
on a couch I really need it because i
don't know why i went to sometimes I
fall asleep on a couch I do weird things
like I wake up and you'll be twisted
like me through my sleep i'm trying to
destroy my my wrist I don't know what's
happening and so this this helps a lot
and not to not to crap on macbooks or
anything because I really like my
macbook but it's I used to have it a
long time ago when I had a job since my
macbook is worsened really yeah because
the way see where there's no it'sit's
square and not the other ones kind of
sloped down right well so it's like this
track pad thingy far from the keyboard
so I can't put like a book here like
there's nothing I can put hit because
when I have like a HP laptop I just put
a book at the end of it okay to elevate
my wrist and then it had no problem I
really can't do that handless if I put
something across the base of the
keyboard here then I'm covering up the
trackpad right then I have to be the guy
with the external mouse I don't want to
be that guy get that you know what is
easy to ask how about this for a long
time I had an external mouse and an
external keyboard that oh wow I spilled
Coors Light all over my watching a Mars
the Mars rover I'll i just remember
where I was when I did this for some
reason but I was watching the Mars rover
on my computer in like a in Omaha oh wow
the comedy condo for the funny bone
there i think i think and i and i was
like oh yeah look at that that's cool
and I'm like getting excited about the
Mars rover and I knocked over entire 24
ounce coors light on my computer is like
oh [ __ ] and I just you know try to clean
it up and Matt it out and dry it off and
they just shut down and I was like oh
and then they got to turn back on but
they're like yeah well your keyboards
kind of fried but you can just get an
external keyboard for like ten bucks
look there it is so I did that and
coughs every up so I did that and my
boss like the first time I pulled that
out of my bag at work he was like what
the [ __ ] are you doing an external
keyboard to get this HP thing he's like
just get a Mac just get a Mac I was like
okay yeah like that's old guys Tech Talk
haha you don't want to be external
external keyboard an external there's
only one thing worse than then literally
pulling out a keyboard and using it for
device that has a keyboard and that is
uh and I've seen this more than once
believe I'm at is the guy who brings his
desktop to starbucks oh yeah I've seen
that's why you saw a TV God as a lot of
other things in his car right that's the
one where they eat a lot of yeah that's
a guy who who we don't know ways living
exactly yeah it puts all he plugs out
let hey where can I put my moto language
who the [ __ ] is doing that how are you
doing that see that that's the thing
about go to the library if you want to
use a [ __ ] working customer service in
places like that like where's the line
of like when you have to ask somebody
you know there's this isn't okay it's
not your public office yeah you can't
bring it but what is if I hold my calls
dude you don't work here because that
also says by the way I'm not leaving
today yeah yeah it's just talk there's
not a lot like I gotta pack this up and
take it to the next place absolutely and
every hour and you know that the problem
with it is starbucks didn't write down
rules for this it's not like they didn't
expect this they were like we're gonna
start a coffee shop and everyone's gonna
pretend like it's their [ __ ] home
office so when someone that manager
comes over and go sir we don't really we
don't allow desktops the guys like his
computer but I can't have right [ __ ] you
know me waves written yet I can't bring
my desktop ring the rule pamphlet out
here let me have a look see goddamn two
screens because he was editing oh my god
its wing web we know an avid machine
yeah yeah I'm just editing it's not a
big deal like it's kind of a big deal
could you guys keep the lights down ya
gotta stay cool in here or the guy that
the guy that has like you don't know
what he's doing but he's got like that
electronic pen and he's just busy
designing is he drawing is he making you
wonder what he's doing grass got nothing
going on in his life why am i mesmerized
by this duties probably just drawing old
band symbols like on his fourth grade
notebook so you are a public writer uh
yeah you like to be in the general point
you need to you are you does your mind
need activity crossing your pass at all
times in order for you to focus meaning
if you put yourself in your house your
most likely intercom yes and no you know
it's weird back this all started because
I just have a roommate this is going
back five years
okay and I was a good guy but he was a
kind of guy like you joked about being
on a podcast I'm not speaking like we
were roommates but it was like his place
you know and just like he just dominated
the common area like I wasn't a guy who
needed to go anywhere I would just sit
up just sit at a desk and do stuff but
like literally his presence it would
like it seeped into my room I get it
would just come under the crack of the
door like so I'd have to get out of it
to just feel like I could get anything
done and that's why that's when I
started and then I kind of liked it I
liked the noise the the like I'm
constantly I drink tea all day and you
know this chicks walking by this is I
like the whole situation yeah all right
so anyway east side or you stay on the
adjacent when you write or you like to
move around I like to move around but I
do a mainly in Pasadena ok ok I'll
highland park and in South Pass but i'll
take my operation anyway like you're
very crazy like I go to a [ __ ]
Starbucks in Malibu well then yeah
that's that's a commitment typically I
would have to have something going on
over there but like if I have something
to do somewhere at 10 then I might just
say boom on up here like five or six
let's go early shoot over there seeing
it's a [ __ ] bed up at starbucks oh it
is rigid only starbucks are you a
starbucks in mainly because I'm locked
into the point system now and I feel bad
about that but your phone to your phone
pair yeah I'm a phone pager at the
starbucks tattoo I'm walking to the
point system I signed a legal contract I
can't drink coffee anywhere else well if
you if you were like a local mom and pop
place you can compete you just need to
give me like a free cup of coffee a free
cup of tea every tenth cup and now and
you just how many cups of tea do you
have a day like is this paying off every
day what's the here's the thing with the
starbucks plan is a once you become a
gold member huh that first cup you pay
for circle John see any circle that
first cup you pay for the other ones are
completely free all right this is a lot
like Scientology is what sounding like
know what's the other one what's the
other thing where it's good at pyramid a
Mason he's am it's all like the maze a
freemason yeah yeah so I i get the thing
is though I said free Stonecutters
absence a lot of people don't know the
policy so
I've had some guys you know they say
things like uh do you just want more hot
water and I'm like no I want another tea
bag that's exactly what another tea bag
go ahead do that and you know and it
they charge you 50 cents but it you
don't get charged that this I feel like
you need to stop me from talking about
this this is like I'm thinking a hole or
something obviously save me I wanted it
like point out also like as much as he's
how about tea is also wearing a sweater
you know what I mean it's got nice well
he's always welcome but yeah banana
republic but now using now that no more
I think because I'm used to seeing you
on stage it's your brain we're very
Brandon yes it we were to that movie but
I guess yellow I've never seen you out
drinking like fifty five cups of tea in
a day and acting like mr. [ __ ] Rogers
so it's like all right that's where are
you from originally I'm his I'm from
Brooklyn but on New York icon yeah that
makes sense oh you're a little bit on
the hipster side huh yeah well no no
come back down there were pre hipster
Yahweh's yeah but I'm kind of lucked
into it now a little bit like for you
growing up like what was the Brooklyn
the Rhode Island that uh well you know
you don't know things are bad until you
leave right so it's not like just
usually really that bad i mean i thought
it did get bad when the crack was the
same a or could this be a clean up phase
yammer when that took place but we was
like to really bring that I was during
and 30 that too okay so late eighties
you remember was coming it was I was
cracked it was it was bad it was bad i
remember one building that I used to
live in but I moved out of that building
his about it was like they fired the
security guard system like it was just
just one of the mill security guards and
they bought in the FOI which stands for
fruits of Islam like they bought in the
the Farrakhan guys Wow because they just
in the hood they get a little bit more
respect something like they wear those
glasses they don't wear police or forms
they arrested but you know who they are
you know they are emanating because they
don't you know you hear stories like
they all know karate and stuff like that
so they're not afraid to kill you you're
a butt karate sounds scary right yeah
well [ __ ] dude i don't so i'm sure right
exactly and I grew up in that in that
Brooklyn and the way thing is uh it's
like I've had a fight i have not had to
fight in my adult life which I'm very
proud of but
growing up it was like weekly daily
fights but really was so and for what
reason it was it was it was it an alpha
male like find your place kind of fights
or just any areas just everyone was so
it just always turned into something
just a lot of reasons a lot of times it
was just uh for me like I just got to
that limit it was a critical mass of
like these are the kids like that that
can [ __ ] with me and we can curse right
these are the kids that can mess with me
and I'll run from them and I couldn't
add any anyone else to that list it just
the list was too big right I remember
riding my bike it can't be everybody
yeah it can't be everybody y'all can't
be on the list so I remember riding my
bike invited my party yeah and his kid I
wasn't that afraid of I'm riding my bike
and he goes uh and i'm on a bike like I
passed him on a bike he can't catch me
with good but he goes he just screams
out I'm gonna lob your bike I'm gonna
steal your bike you know or take your
bike I I hit the brakes come get off and
I just lump them up just I don't there's
no talking I just punch him in the face
like six times Wow I get back on a bike
like you are not gonna take my bag not
only that no you're never gonna think
about to go like or even yelling at me
again yeah that's not gonna happen with
you and now another kid mammy of pedals
a yes so chase me [ __ ] and get
it you know I forget um there's been a
you know that's a beauty of Netflix is
so much information and every once a
while um use I stumble across some
documentaries talking about uh New York
back in the day or you watch older
movies from like the seventies in New
your and you forget gadget hole it
literally there really was like the
Disneyland and it looks like now it
really was there were still really like
burnt out like whole horses the cities
that were just and lapit ated and things
you really had and like forty-second
Street oh man it was fun because back
then you go to 42nd Street you see two
movies for the price of one either to
karate flicks or whatever they were
playing you was to movies but it was you
take in life you know your life into
your own hand right we would go down all
the time because like two movies the
price of one we just couldn't don't mind
we can see two movies we only pay for
what is that even resist any better
like all costs of a movie was like 4 45
hours you see two movies and did you
have brothers and sisters I did but
they're a lot younger than me they they
don't they don't they never experienced
the New York I experienced that how much
younger 11 years younger well my okay my
stepsister's like two years younger than
me but my brothers and sisters like
we're all from islands believe it or not
like I'm from Coney Island which is
really a peninsula but my siblings are
from roosevelt island which people don't
even know about it's just a small little
island underneath the 59th Street bridge
okay it's in in the East River it's
night and day like they grew up like
with just enough New York you know the
slang they they're very Island is so
small isn't it it's you could do a rock
across the whole thing I promise you I
think I've seen it when it was like do
people live there and yeah like they're
like five houses or something looks like
the tiny will they keep building on it
but a crow it's like a mile and a half
long right people it's not even beyond
the only like but across its it's like
not two blocks across like I'm serious
uh you got 12 football all the way
across let's go out and play baseball
are we lost the ball in the river again
we're done I would ask the ball in the
river but probably 3,000 people in it
because they they they have so many high
rises yeah and that's where they grew up
oh maybe I'm thinking of a different
little island I saw because I'm ever
seen something like there's leggins
eight people yeah maybe okay like a
three-hour tour something right right
that's something but then the Harlem
Globetrotters were there so that was
good so they they grew up on that island
and it's good it's good it's good
growing up without violence if you can
if you can help it I know if I [ __ ] it
works good words good words of wisdom
yeah put that on a fortune cookie which
is interesting that that um i would
never would have pegged you for the guy
that was getting into fights growing up
I think I I only ever got into to write
and it was just more of like the more of
a Hulk rage fight where someone just
wouldn't leave me alone and I was like
if I gotta fight I was not a fighter you
know and I I always assume that most
people that I know like you can feel
that energy like oh this person used to
always get in some fisticuffs oh it's
not mine mix in it I would never have
pegged you as right get up also fight
there's a little
that like smiles a lot real friendly now
but like back in the day like I could
see like it's like Denzel in uh the
equalizer like yeah I didn't have you
have to say a lot he doesn't have to say
a lot it's like he's like look you're
gonna take me for this or you're not and
that's the deal and I just think there's
a lot of there's a calmness about Dwayne
that says to me I would never sneak up
behind Michael yeah tickle fight and
then right get an elbow to the face or
something did you go ahead no you would
I would think about other people and
tickle fight them okay that's good to
know is that i vs you like Rebecca miss
connection I try to tickle fight you on
the sub was actually a thing turn
lighting all parties yeah there's a
whole section well then yeah I'm gonna
go to the tickle fight I'm sexy crazy
with it how long did you live in that it
would be so basically take is like GTA
eight and then yet time with the college
in Long Island yeah and uh yeah I don't
think I didn't have any fights in
college either just like to believe at
some point you guys with some argument
fight my way through everything yeah we
know to the thing is that these fights
when I'm I'm like a little kid like by
the time I'm like my last fight fight
was like 14 I think so high school kind
of combat what ya did you don't really
think that's when the Tyrone a kicks in
hardcore it is but like when I'm from
like I'm a type of guy you can tell me
something and like I don't fact checked
it I just I just do it like someone told
me like just like I had a job and they
bought in this corporate coach and she
just mentioned in passing like we were
eating she mentioned in passing you know
you have food digests better if you
don't drink while you eat it you should
wait like 15 minutes and I was like okay
and I did that for like 10 years like I
never you know the fact they were like
dr. is this right so I heard somewhere
that like for black men right the
greatest risk of getting shot and killed
it was like until you're 25 right then
it like drops down so like by the time I
was like 15 I was like I can't really
get into fights anymore people have gone
you have gone looking knives yeah just
you and some kid yelling about a bike
right I who's now got his you know his
[ __ ] he's got to prove himself and
show you what he has a worst life at
home exactly yeah right I think you have
a joke about that whole thing of
like people what what are people you
know but there's a football is a
football joke right yeah right right I
playing for exactly exactly four sides
of the park right you know and it
doesn't really matter how tough you are
even if you from the same place once
it's established that you have something
to live for and they may unfortunately
not and you that's not a person you can
fight no no if you can help it yeah so I
began to have something to live for not
that I was a comedian yet but like you
know you could see a like college was
wanted a few Jane and you wanted to live
right was that ingrained in you through
your family are you are you do come from
your parents your parents together i
know now they let her stay together no
no no they're not educated super
educated my grandmother a little bit my
grandmother was from the south she's
very like she made her share of mistakes
but she still had that southern way
about her and like black people say
things like you know act extra age not
your color that's a that's a thing like
people say which means act the right way
you know so yeah college was always
because I I did well in school it became
a thing it wasn't like I'm from a place
where people go to college okay it was
just sort of like and it wasn't like
people no one you know my family would
like do your homework and all of that I
just kept bringing home A's and they
were like oh [ __ ] well maybe we should
go to college yeah by yourself with no
outside pressure so you actually you
know I I person I hated high school I
was I did whatever I had to just to get
by like us for me was a victory but I'm
fine with that so I always wonder the
mind of someone who's not being pushed
to get a's like Frank what was it just
for you like what do you think and I
don't mean this in an arrogant way for
you to answer but like was was homework
kind of easy for you um yeah it was I
mean high school wasn't super easy
because there's a lot of it and I had a
job but it wasn't too bad whenever I
applied myself it was quite easy and I
think the only bad thing is not knowing
your competition like the reason why you
see like NBA NBA players and his sons
become NBA players it's not only jeans
it's context it's that fault like it's
like like stuff car Steph Curry's father
Dale told them when he was in high
school you kind of shoot from the hip
you got to change your host
mike who else is gonna tell you the
changer and it goes in right your
current shot goes in right but your dad
goes first that shot is done you gotta
it won't work and he spends the whole
summer changing his shot right so that
was my only downfall was like being a
little bit better than people around me
not knowing there were people better
than me or as good as me you didn't have
the mental a challenge you right all
right listen you could take it to the
next level right when I still did all
right yeah uh athletics did you add were
you know that I can Circle it a little
bit academia yeah where you're at they
call me Wizkid went from like I was the
only one in my neighborhood to have a
computer like 11 or 22 have a computer
or just stuff that you brought out of
here right I mean mainly play games with
people would come and you know I met
older met online right yes rooms at you
weren't supposed two games a hundred
chat room or your 1295 you paid for AOL
AOL disk you have an hours of peace
everyone's like oh my god Dwayne's a
wizard that's great don't see people
have no idea what it was like that that
open world of the first and I even
looking that disk and going oh my god I
put this in there's a whole world out
there I get to talk to and then it's
just some guy going what's your name how
old is the first thing that happens to
you is just an attack on you it's like
was the it was the moderate it was the
it was the first like uh chatroulette
candy like they put it in an exactly
there's a dick all right great um so did
you do theater like where did your
desire to become an entertainer when did
it start when it when was the angling of
it was too long huh you know I was I
would make people laugh but but people
know me completely I'm like a I'm an
all-purpose person like I'm a completely
different person in different settings
so like my family on my father said they
heard I was on comedy like he doesn't
even talk like how's he doing comedy
like so they knew me is just a small
quiet guy my mother's side of the family
thought I was funny and growing up
people in my neighborhood some thought I
was finally some thought I didn't talk
at all I think I played in the Wiz when
I was like in fifth grade the Scarecrow
in The Wiz cuz my music music teacher
heard I could dance because I used to
pop a little bit oh yeah
pop it lock ha black and stuff yeah give
us a demonstration for the listeners oh
my god was awesome yeah great moves
that's impressive so yeah i don't i
don't know i think in an in college I
started like doing more things I think
it happened like I was always a fan of
comedy stand-up and then it wasn't until
college I realized I could have stand up
then so so you actually got to do a
stand-up collar early to learn to figure
it out yeah yeah what what happened was
um this guy I knew we did a we did a
show at school where we was like the
Apollo at my college and we tried to
wrap me in this other guy tried to wrap
he was actually better than I was his
name is Magic Wand he actually went on
to be a pretty big rapper in like Latin
America magic juan 'magic wine hilarious
and uh I think he's Dominican but he
wrapped in Spanish sure and he did his
thing so he never got to his part of his
rap because I we got booed when I was
rapping right you start will finish with
thunder and you like now we're not gonna
get asked me so we got booed and it
didn't come and sweep you off the stage
yeah it was a whole you know yeah but
the rap though is like they have to know
the song either data you have to be
really aggressive right they don't know
the song is like what is this right so
anyway one of the guys who was my backup
dancer we we had the whole thing like he
came back two years later once summer
and he's like I started stand-up I'm
like what do you mean start a stand-up
he's like I just stand up and I wear
when you first hear you're like well be
more much just do stand-up yeah you
assume that there's this some weird path
that ready okay right so you were
completely you became a like intrigued
at that moment of yeah yes a lot of
funny guy but I'm like you're doing
stand-up I'm funnier than your house sit
down so and then like that what people
don't here's the thing uh I had a job
interview one summer at Microsoft which
is crazy i don't even know how i talked
my way into this to like test software
at a computer when you were ten they fly
me out to seattle and uh to this day my
mother told me to write a thank you
letter and I didn't write the thank you
letter and I think that hurt me because
I also realize answered one question
wrong and I should have I didn't get the
job but I had already
written down if I don't get this
Microsoft job i'm gonna start stand up
so that's what you wrote down said it
but thank you letter you have a note to
yourself somewhere that says yeah wrote
this I wrote it down on paper no I don't
still have it was a thank you letter
supposed to tell them thank you for not
hiring me because now I know but before
before before I yeah before like right
after for meeting with me thank you
thank you for meeting with me oh you
know I answer that one question wrong
blah blah you know that kind of thing
yeah and I think I was a little nervous
at the interview and uh but nerves are
never good like I'm learning now that
like when I was a kid I used to be like
such a dick it's so overconfident and
then I'm like being around other people
I felt like oh this is no way to be and
I think I went too far the other side I
think it's okay to be a little you know
now on yourself and what you're doing
yeah yeah and I'm back to like talking
my [ __ ] my Brooklyn [ __ ] you know I mean
you know not always but so sorry but
there's a difference between well
there's a difference be like talking
[ __ ] and then I'm like you're also out
doing things like if you're just a guy I
knew who died didn't stand up with every
once a while you're like oh yeah I'm
gonna write a movie I'm gonna do this
it's like okay yeah we're all gonna do a
lot of gray but you actually went out
you did some of these things it's like
okay then you you're you're working
towards a goal you're working to move
forward and that I mean you must like
you must enjoy it which brings you to my
like my overall question which was was
stand up the driving force field like
did you want to be a stand-up was that
the priority or were you thinking
yourself I'm more interested in like
television or film or directing or we're
like what was your I don't think I
thought about it at all that that that
deeply but I wanted to be funny I wanted
to be a stand-up and then actually I
think a lot of the acting and stuff
which is great and I do it once you come
to LA you gotta expand you hustle right
yeah I don't think you have to but I
think it's for someone like you I think
it's important that we all do as much as
we can write without narrowing it down
to like I'm just a commercial actor I'm
just a [ __ ] comedian and and so it's
been fun to expand I think I like
telling stories is at the end of the day
and so yeah sometimes I wish I stuck
like a state of New York maybe another
year or two I mean I was in Boston
actually I moved to Boston but I wish I
stayed in New York a little longer and
focus primarily on stand up but I like
my life you know like when
but I do think I was kind of in with
those New York guys who like you know
they don't like la guys they think it's
less awful form and blah blah blah just
want to be on TV yeah so when I moved
out here I think they some of my new
york people cast me away and of course
yeah and how many of them are out here
now summon a lot of them how many of
them stop doing comedy the ones that did
move out here right ah good for that um
tell me do you remember the first time
you decided where and when you
absolutely yeah absolutely remember your
first joke I remember my first set of
jokes i'm not sure what I did first well
what happened was that guy that I knew
was doing comedy I didn't get the job at
Microsoft instead I was working at some
like a like a chaw benefit firm I had a
summer gig though and then I went to the
black expo which is a thing that happens
and cities all around the country where
it's a showcase of black businesses like
okay talking about like early 90s so
it's like support black businesses and
you go and you learn and you know they
have deals know like up and there's a
comedy club there oh my god you guys are
having secret meetings yeah at all I
didn't know there was a thing like that
yes it is a comedy club yourself with
the mural you understand why you wanted
what I know what send me the memo I
think you might be a little white I
think I think they're white people there
this Lawrence jacob javits center in new
york city west side and the convention
center so there's a comedy club day I
woke up to them I go how how do you do
comedy how do you start and they go oh
come every Wednesday we have a showcase
on Wednesday we do the open mic on on
that the new they call it the new Jax we
did a new jack segment on Sunday I'm
like okay but and as I'm telling you the
story I'm realizing how much me and my
little brother I like because he has
such he's way way beyond me his tunnel
vision is is epic I'll tell you stories
about its epic but I'm realizing this
was a bit bit of tunnel vision so they
told me that that wednesday i went to a
little meeting and they they it was like
a like an hour thing and go his joke
it's set up you know premise that a
punch like a thing like yeah
so before you took the stage like listen
will will help you feel they were they
were amazing and it and it was um
actually I'm gonna I'm not even killing
you in the that room with me like guys
who wanted to do comedy it's me it's
Tracy Morgan rich Pierre right and with
what can just sit in there and the guys
telling us a material IV who's passed
away he's showing us comedy and in that
Sunday I go to a show just to watch I
see Tracy Morgan get on stage for the
first time ever I don't really tell the
story he [ __ ] kills oh really she was
just amazing get-go it's just like by
the way yeah I'm [ __ ] hilarious he's
amazing like his his final bit was like
a bust a rhyme thing he did a parody and
I did a parody to when I finally he did
a parody of the scenario okay we go yo
here we go yo so what so he says he's
like he's like Buster mom has it was it
killed trust me it's not gonna kill
anybody goes because I he's like Oh
Buster mom has those big dick sucking
lips everyone just loses it and then he
starts doing Buster Romney goes as I
combine all the dicks I could find man
were just [ __ ] everyone who loses it
everyone completely loses it be sure to
follow him no knows that I didn't go
that week okay okay so wednesday i go to
the uptown for the little seminar friday
i go to the improv in like not that's
this is all in harlem when I'm telling
okay friday i go to like the like a
regular mainstream show I see William
statements and some other people at the
improv that's a good show and then
Sunday I see Tracy the next Sunday I go
on stage and I I do i do five minutes
and I kill you know then the next sunday
i bought were you the first one first
one you had that beginner's luck you had
I oh yeah I but did you prepare a lot
yeah you like all right I got a cat me
well you memorized you just did you or
did you go up ago I'd here's my idea no
no I had some jokes ready I had just
stupid stuff had something like my
girlfriend won't blow my horn and you
know and then something like out of it
how did that joke oh it was in it was
basically her system I was gonna like
get her sister to blow me or since I had
been blowing you
as opposed to her but it was all blow
your horn then I did my own I did at two
parodies i did a Stevie Wonder junk food
fever instead of jungle fever it was
what if jungle fever was written for
Roseanne Barr I think it would have gone
a little something like this and I put
the glasses on and I I've got junk food
fever can say no to pizza and it's a big
thing yeah tell me there wasn't a little
bit of weird al inspiration yeah right
exactly oh my god and then i do Michael
Jackson do you do it not not proud of
this but I saw some guys do it after and
I let it let it go but I did do you
remember the time when I used to be
black Michael Jackson and um yeah that
was that yeah that's a lot in five
minutes by the way yeah yeah and it's
like it seemed like forever it did but
and it's also matt it's not a precursor
of like what I was going to become as a
nose of a writer who's really weird like
even saying it I'm like that's what I'm
gonna say I was gonna point a point the
funny thing is that you don't do
anything like that anymore you're not up
there doing parodies you're not putting
on [ __ ] glasses being stevie wonder
you don't even do impressions you go on
obviously you do you tell stories about
right this is not a reverence was this
is this is what I always told people the
first time I desire to do stand-up i
watch it a couple times and then I knew
that I had a book to gig right it was at
a comedy club and I'm in was kind of in
Milwaukee so you knew and and the minute
because you know there's a threshold
right like the anxiety is that first
step on stage like it's a different
world but there's that you're part of
the audience part of the audience part
of the regular world step onto the stage
everything your whole dynamic zactly
yeah I've always told people that in for
me that once that perspective changes
because no one really understands they
don't see what you see so when you get
up there you either realize at that
moment you're comfortable and you go I
could I can live up here and then
regardless of how you do Ryan kill not
kill eat it did it feel like you
belonged up there absolutely I realized
after my first set when I walked away I
was like I can do this I actually really
liked being up there as weird and at the
anxiety all the weird things that go on
in your head
I was ok with us all what I will not be
afraid to go up there definitely
definitely and and you know I mean if
you are afraid you'll never let that
stop you from going up now so when you
went up did you feel like I belong up
here absolutely thing to think but I
remember dating this girl I was dating
at the time she lived in Baltimore and
uh I was sort of giving her to play by
play and she was like you know how did
it go blah blah blah and I was like oh
well she was like oh wow that's great
you guys I was like but even if I had
going bad this is what I'm doing this
thing this is what I'm doing it yeah and
I I was all over the place I was also a
time I was dropping on his hip hop dance
class from time to time and I went to
this hip hop then well-rounded rounded
and I swear to you I got recognized at
the hip hop dance class I had someone
saw you once once once ever in this girl
at the hip hop dance clubs like your
comedian right it was like yes yeah yeah
they fold and it would that that kind of
feel that too I mean she like it was
literally that week she said you're a
comedian that like oh you tried to do
comedy [ __ ] Christ having a struggle
through five minutes of nonsense
yesterday you're not gonna do that again
are you so this is um so this was in
Harlem your first time and yes did you
wanna stay in that area or how did you
develop and use that you said that yeah
so what happened to me is that was cell
in college so okay I I did I was doing
it like once in a blue welcome home okay
oh you didn't do it out you didn't do it
you'll do it at home huh right we know
only note back see college was Long
Island and home was the signature
there's nothing in my college there was
nothing there or you just didn't have
the time no I would just when I went
back to school I would like host shows I
would host talent shows and things like
that okay been a traditional state and
I'd be funny in between but mainly
cracking jokes on people I new kind of
thing and when I went home to visit my
mom I dip in and go to Harlem and try to
do a show so it was like the progress
wasn't but meanwhile think you were only
comfortable doing comedy kind of where
you were from UM no you know not really
i didn't use this all i knew right and
it was actually the reverse really and
you'd rather do it anywhere else and the
reason why was a clean comic to is
because uh they at the time I've always
liked to look too young
was and I was in my twenties what they
didn't buy it so I think I couldn't be
dirty you know was like yeah you could
be upbeat noisy like they like they like
a ride a bike west on you yet about the
audience audience right you had this
vibe and you thought yourself okay i'm
doing this joke and they're not buying
it cuz the way right they dictated to me
that i was going to be clean yeah
because they I looked younger than I was
and it is then buy it we get you were
the kid yeah kid should be that way I'm
so pretty clean right I'm so pretty
clean that's what started so I was like
I started clean in black rooms which is
weird like had a shot at not in black
rooms I may have been dirty butt but
like like the guy after me before me was
gonna talk about [ __ ] yeah they were
like well we don't want you to talk
about that just do something else yeah
they'd it was it that's when I at least
that's what I got from them also my
grandmother was still alive my siblings
were really young so in my mind I was
always like wanted to be able to do a
show that they could see and so that
kind of that's a pretty uh yeah that's a
nice noble I like that attitude but you
also don't get you a lot more work at
all yeah well that's a matter is I write
more opportunity really does opportune
or first gig bag I mean I think it I
think superstardom maybe being dirty can
help if you're dirty and vulnerable like
you just can't be dirty but if you're
dirty and you're Richard Pryor you know
I do i do think kids like to sneak in
and watch something that's dirty and so
you get that that bad thing but clean
definitely worked and I what happened
with me is I got a job in Boston when I
graduated so is that where you really
kicked off yeah right Zach so then so
then like cuz that's how you us how her
first met you someone to tell you the
Boston comic yeah I am a boss a comic in
that sense that's how you identify
yourself yeah because I was an open mic
Estill I was by that time i'm still
doing comedy only in harlem and
sometimes like in a village and then i
moved to Boston and then it was all that
scene and that was all I was doing at
that point I already talked about how
hard New York is yeah I've heard it is
not easy to get into the Boston same
room it wasn't that hard for me I think
I think Boston comics destroy and it's
it's a really great place to learn
comedy okay and
for it's weird because my my pacing is
not typical of a Boston comic probably
because I'm actually fun New York but um
it's a good place to learn comedy I
don't know if it's hard to get in I
think New York is harder but I think
Boston is a better training ground I
like Patrice O'Neal was from Boston bill
burr Dane Cook Gary Gulman Bobby Kelly
these are the guys they like much forget
that Bobby Kelly started yeah and Boston
me and Gary were in the same class those
guys were a little bit about a little
bit ahead of us and those guys went to
New York and just it was like it was
child's play when they got to New York
it was like they it was a seismic boom
because they were in boston they were
killing so hard yeah under the guys
above us with the old-school guys like
Frank Santorelli Kevin Knox got rest his
soul and you know Don Gavin and Steve
Sweeney these guys destroy and what do
you think it is it's Boston is it's it's
repressed the whole thing replace it's a
everyone's funny so if you're going to
be a comic you have to be that much
funnier because everyone's funny the the
cab driver is funny the guy 7-eleven is
funny everyone is hysterical everyone's
cynical as [ __ ] yeah sarcastic as [ __ ]
so you have to just busting balls
constantly constantly busting balls so
if you're gonna be like the guy they go
to see what do you got it yeah you
better be funnier than my next door
neighbor Larry reckon he just [ __ ]
made fun of my fat wife the other day
and made me laugh my ass also than this
this is interesting to me then but you
didn't adapt to that style yet you you
succeeded in there so why do you think
that was is the difference problem yeah
i just it i don't know sort of like uh
not from the audience standpoint but
yeah i mean is you know a lot of
comments you have to rise you up right
they they any kind of go are your in
will let you go will let you pass so you
know I don't Apollo was intercepted just
being different mmm you know so if they
were talking fast I was talking slow but
if I could make the jokes hit hard
enough then I had my thing you know also
I was I was back then I was really good
friends with Patrice so I'm sure he had
an impact on me that I you know wasn't
quite aware of I do yeah and how and so
how long did you stay in Boston before
you're like all right I guess
gotta go to New Yorkers exciting
happening you can feel like I gotta
graduate I gotta go there a weekend and
I just took off for New York that's what
happens I'm from New York so I'm
starting to dip down into New York back
then I got an 800 pager number yes I
told two or three clubs in New York that
I lived in New York and when I was still
living in Boston still working and they
would page me like that the day of or
the day before and I would drive from
Boston to New York which is like four
hours and just do to set and then when
you say do the set how much time 10
three minutes yeah do the set and then
either drive right back to Boston so
like get off stage at like nine ten
drive back to Boston and go to work the
next day or go to my mom's place in New
York and get up at like 4am and drive
straight to work you know to get to work
at like eight and be at my desk a
doughnut I get it man I used to when I
first looked out I lived in san diego
and i would get it i would get a gig up
here in Los Angeles and you know there
was a lot of times where it's like it's
three o'clock in the morning and you're
like do I stay here do I got like you
you drive out a lot of time is spent
getting to and from a gig for 7 to 10 or
15 but not you could work you could put
anywhere again three to eight hours yes
just to get those ten even in Boston I
used to go to New Hampshire on Tuesday
nights to do like a five or ten minutes
set and that was like an hour and a half
so it was like a lot of yeah and so I
think what happens is you have the time
it just so right because if you do that
and you get it to a good a certain point
and then you come to LA oh then you go
to New York and you have to do it again
that's what some guys say [ __ ] that i'm
not doing all that again at the time it
just so so you have enough in a tank to
put to pay a little bit more dues yeah
yeah and so that's at that point cuz
you're right once you go somewhere like
a New Yorker la you kind of I mean
unless you've already blown up or
already have a TV show you have to kind
of start you know yours the bottom and
then I didn't come in till I did Conan I
had a conan under my belt and I still
couldn't get in with every club right
even with the conan with me a New Yorker
Conan has my weight but okay I was here
doing coffee shop
so like you know yeah and you will do
we're not expecting that you're like I
did Conan everybody why am I I wasn't
but I didn't III just a pretty quick as
I guess that's what it is and this
started your love of coffee shops yes
bringing it back around everything did
you up do comedy in New York before you
came out to Los Angeles well I really
didn't like so okay I mean I was an open
mic in New York then I moved to Boston
got my legs and then I was planning my
trip planning to move back to New York
and I moved here instead I took a right
turn on my way right so you only ever
just dabbled in New York per se yeah
like I'm you know like I never got in
with the seller I'm in with the Gotham
is all post now this is after you yeah
right right you've done I it to that I
was doing it doesn't exist anymore so
the Boston comedy club in New York very
confusing that no that's that's where I
think I met you that could be yeah I
that yeah I literally read you know
remember Ramsey more absolutely yeah
yeah uh he passed away yeah I did he
pass away last year unfortunately but uh
he was he came on Punk'd once and he was
like he was like he was always on the
show but one of his first times on the
show he's like hey aren't you a comic
too and I go yeah yeah you do stand-up
he's like yeah I run this room at the
knitting factory so I started going down
there and he's like he's like I said I
one day I mentioned like me and I'd love
to get out to New York as I go you never
done comedy New York I was like no and
he's like okay I mean calls Wayne rey de
who then like I distinct Wayne yeah
Wayne is like likes by some people
disliked by other people he's up and
down but but he just goes he could get
to hold me as a que over New York Ramsey
says you're funny call me I'll put you
on at the Boston comedy club I was like
okay well I'm coming out to New York and
I flew myself out there and I wow that's
crazy it was literally yeah I stayed at
a hotel every like near Central Park
which is not near the Boston gonna win I
had no idea what I was tied sweat i
maneuvered New York all by myself to get
to the Boston comedy club there's girl I
went to college with was in the back and
Jay Davis was the only other person in
the room I recognized wow he was out
there from out of town and the guy goes
hey I'm gonna put you on to jdavis I go
okay great and Jay had one of the better
sets i've ever seen Jay have and I was
like oh good cool and then I went on and
I for some reason changed a few jokes
around because I thought different
it's not la Rey and I think that hurt me
a little but I think all in all it was
an okay set how cool the guy was like
yeah do that was good just try to loosen
up a little more and come back to the
middle show and undulate show so I
literally went around the corner did
another show came back to the show I did
five shows in one night was like well
this is New York I [ __ ] I like it but
but I do feel like Boston comedy club
was the first place that I saw you or
met you yeah that was it was called the
Boston comedy club because uh Barry cats
used to own it nice and he's from Boston
and when he moved to New York it was
like a club for Boston comics to go and
work out that's that was the theory at
least it turned into something else but
it became the eastville comedy club
eventually came into a county club so
yeah I never I've never lived in New
York I've gone back a lot i was dating a
girl a while and I would you know go few
weeks at a pop so I kind of missed that
experience I do think that that was like
my next thing was to go to New York
which I still think I might have to do
and just get up like 20 times a week
yeah i mean i do as much as I can here
but but you spent you know in your early
years you obviously would travel to
manhattan so you have a go there like
stuff but professional standpoint was
not really your play road no no just
wash started and then boston is where I
you know realize that men so the conan
thing yes that was your first TV uh
something that happened you from a TV
related standpoint yeah how did that all
come about in and what was that like was
it something was it was there an
expectation of yours of like i gotta get
on one of these TV shows or did it just
kind of have it kind of happened you
know and i look at the set and i think i
think it went well but i looked at the
set recently and I was like oh I've
stuff you know like it was fine but it
was tough to watch what happened was I
did the Chicago Comedy Festival this is
gone a while back and it was going well
I did I have one really bad set at the
Chicago Comedy Festival I just was
nervous this is black from Chicago and I
like Chicago uh audiences are great you
know but I said but you do very well in
Chicago this is little thing with the
black with chicago and new york already
have a there's like a thing you know
like
and do we look like we would know now we
have no idea well no you know Chicago is
a second city so you know oh they have a
thing against each other yes sure it's
not as bad as New York in Boston but
it's a little thing yeah and then black
people from Chicago uh they they're like
they have the perfect mix of being
metropolitan but also having that's that
country at southern sensibility where's
New York we lost it like we just the
southern sensibility is gone because
yeah we kind of like too far up with
like Caribbean and regular black with
like Latin stuff mixed in and we still
have like the connection but we're not
went at a southern it's you don't hear
it enough speaking and you're more savvy
and less have some lemonade right we're
more like yo son as opposed to uh you
know y'all come back now ya so I have a
bad set whatever it that that said ends
with me going [ __ ] y'all right dr. Mike
and then a guy was thing or that
ninety-nine point nine percent clean you
drop the mic with a [ __ ] y'all yeah it
was going back right so you know I wait
for the swear word of my closer and then
I tell I want to stick it and I remember
the guy hosting Joe I think his name is
George were born great comic he had to
clean it up and he's making fun of me
and I'm leaving I'm all upset and in my
next add another show though so then I
go to Zanies and I do a show same day
same same like a like and a half hour
late half hour I i do really well as a
me some guy comes up to me who I don't
even know I can't remember who was he's
like I just saw you I can at that other
place he was like this was great now I
get it you know what I mean anyway the
next day two days late on back in Boston
for these Conan auditions then you know
interesting now I'm realizing some
because it was that this place called
the Hong Kong the comedy studio which is
like the alt seen in Boston and I I'm
just now realizing that I should the off
scene was the seeds were being planted
right then and I should have stayed
really close to the old same because I
had friends in that scene I was cool
with them I'm just now realizing that
even then the industry had started to go
to the office in yeah to get talent so
I'm about to go on everyone's nervous
one's taking this stupid advice I forget
who gave it to her stuff like when you
get on stage for the conan people you
know just go ahead and see a set they
don't like it when you say hey how's it
going you know like dumb stuff like that
like if you need to say how's it going
hey how's it going but why how I was so
relaxed is literally like 5-10 minutes
before my set a guy walks up to me he's
the Booker from Conan and he says I saw
you in chicago last night you were great
and he just was like you were great and
i like this almost like insinuating this
was a formality yeah sorry says God to
do this this is the guy saw you turn I'm
that guy like that he just saw me at
zanies sorry because you nights before
yeah and he was like you were great and
I felt bad cuz everyone so nervous my
comedy friends and I'm like I don't know
if you guys heard but I was writing
Chicago never got this yeah and so then
I do really well and then I get a call
at work I was at working at a company
called uh well they were called digital
may have changed the name at that point
a digital became compact so I was either
working at the time for digital compact
or like staples corporate office but I
was doing y2k stuff so I was literally
just going through code and making the
two digits four digits that kind of
stuff you're trying to stop the world
from collapsing right right very
important stuff and so I get a call at
work you know from the conan people
they're like oh we got a date and I'm
like oh thank you hang up the phone and
I'm very excited and you know pump my
fist and that's it yeah now TV is
obviously a lot different when you first
take the stage for 20 yeah right so I
don't want to think about calling thing
is as you say there was a little detour
like I'm in Boston at that time but I
just moved back to Boston from LA oh so
I actually moved to LA it was only for
six months I went to grad school see you
visited yeah i was going to grad school
at USC okay it's gonna get an MBA and I
was still going comedy grad schools not
that tough but it's kind of tough like
everyone there was really smart and you
gotta want to learn when you go to gross
yeah and it has [ __ ] around well the
tests are really hard it's like it's not
like they all look like that a right
answer you're like when you're an
undergrad it's like
you could argue that any of these are
you psyched it's like the edge the
choices like cheese green eight and fan
and you're looking for a number or must
be eight you know but in grad school
they all look like the right answer but
I was doing all right but I left grad
school because this girl I was dating in
Boston maybe she had our own reasons she
was like what are you doing you a
comedian are you what are you doing I
was like you're right so left grad
school at a job left grad school at her
at school and her no I went back with
her in the boss there no we went back to
be her in Boston I had a job in the Bay
Area lined up so my life could have been
any yeah I had a job lined up in a bay
area to do project development but at
the same time well so I go to the Bay
Area am i doing comedy or my doing
project development and my but who knows
I could have hooked up with like
Zuckerberg I don't know i don't think i
don't like to think about it but I go
back to Boston and my goal was I need to
get on TV before the people i was in
school with graduate and get their mba
and like a good goal yeah to make to
make them see like young no I was
correct when I so yeah my Conan was
about like a month after they graduated
so that's pretty good yeah that's pretty
good those [ __ ] book learners may
show them just so the listeners
understand that's not normally how it
works you know you don't have it planned
yes to God alone in next month and then
you get to get out and television
doesn't really go along with your plans
per se Matt's happen to you know I I'm
constantly making those kind of plans
that's okay and I don't discourage I
just keep making them that's fine yeah
that's I think the more optimistic and
positive you are and and goal-oriented
you can be in the city the better off
you'll take i want a deal anyway i
bought a suit and where was I Korea I
got a suit made custom made it was me i
was with burton and a jimmy schubert
right we all got suits and I and you
know my name is inside the suit and I'm
like this is my leatherman suit I won't
wait a suit till I do Letterman I've
never done let him in i missed that
window but the suit i get back home is
sooo fits okay maleta masood i'm waiting
and waiting and I'm like I don't know if
I'm gonna do let him in my little
brother has a med school interview he
needs a suit and I give him my letterman
suit anyways that to his med school
interview he gets into med school after
because the zoo med school soon it
became the med school suit yeah yeah
dude that's so that's amazing um I know
where price no we're fine ok cool so so
I'm always intrigued by peoples you know
their first experiences so your first
experience in television I mean yeah you
get it be you this is not a world you're
in so walking in to say okay now it's
time to go on TV yeah it's not like it's
time for another set at a comedy club
laughs yeah it's it's the band was
laughing so that helped I got bumped my
first time okay so you're saying about
so did you give up previous or did you
actually have to go sit through it
assume you're going up and then they
eventually come and go you don't go yeah
like I was there my family was there and
it was a I saw this I saw him recently i
forgot to mention it to him I can't
believe I don't know why I forgot this
but Adam Sandler was on and Vince
McMahon and he just both went long and
then it came to me and like he got
bumped and but they sent me in my family
to Ruby Foos which is a really nice
chinese restaurant at the time i was
getting into chinese food big time and
thai food and everything my siblings
they didn't get it quite so we went
there and they ought it like chicken
wings have some garbage and I would have
some really good spring rolls and they
said it was me my English teacher from
high school who I'm still really good
friends with her husband and my family
and because none of us are drinkers they
were so stoked like when I got the bill
actually called me they were like feel
like we sent you all out to eat it was
nothing was I was like oh yeah well we
you know we ate alcohol is ninety
percent of every right hey I don't drink
the bill is like fourteen dollars it was
so happy was that who knew that that
would actually trigger them to be a head
like to actually we gotta have Dwayne
back again because we bump him it only
cost us 10 50 to send 40 of his family
members out to eat so how long between
the bump and getting back on about three
weeks okay no but but you're racking
guys I feel like I would just be
sweating that letter three weeks racking
but did you ever at one point go maybe
I'll never get on because it's not shy
never never but like my mom it made me
think I should be more like my mom and
which I am naturally and I still
struggle with that today cuz my mom is a
type to tell nobody anything she tells
you nothing
because she's afraid some people are
wishing against her which i think is a
real thing right it is so you tell like
a thousand people I'm gonna be on Conan
and eight eight hundred happy two
hundred like [ __ ] that guy yeah you get
bumped your like i wonder if there's 200
people were praying every day that I got
bumped so now you're like I'm not
telling anyone anything till there's but
then no one knows anything and you got
stuff going on that that dude we talked
about this a lot on the show is like
they're the fine line of self-promotion
and sounding like a [ __ ] bragging
[ __ ] yeah right i mean it's a fine
line cuz again you do have stuff going
on and you want there are people that
follow you online social media Facebook
Twitter whatever that do give a [ __ ] but
you're right thank you I have 5,000
friends you think all five thousand feel
like God John we want you to succeed no
there are some that are like I [ __ ]
hated you in high school yeah gonna hurt
you even more we'll be following it i
watch you fail cannot wait till you
implode oh you didn't get last comic
standing haha [ __ ] you right right you
know I saw a method man on what show is
it it was some talk show it was like I
like my Jimmy Kimmel or something with
the other Wutang Clint members it was
like four or five voting members and
method man and uh whoever the host was
they were like so meth now you've got a
new show coming out with red man this
year right and the other will Changmin
they turned a method like what he's like
oh yeah didn't tell you guys yet and I
was like well if MF isn't telling the
other members yet I don't need to be
tellin anybody on Facebook right thank
you do you feel like this is that
because you went through the dry run of
Conan when you got back the second time
it was let it was more familiar to use
you're like oh yeah I know all this part
of the process leading up to this part f
initely help me and kind of feel like
all right I've already I familiar with
the crew Andriano all the other
absolutely I'm still a little nervous on
stage and I got a chance to walk out
there and i still had nervous but it
helped a lot and i went second so like
that all my comments have been great
because they haven't really sweat it
they've never swept me on time it's
always been like if it's five ish oh wow
they've been like okay that's good
because usually they want like four and
a half right yeah yeah they've been I
went second on so comics always you know
eighty ninety percent of time you go
last but going second is kind of cool
because it was almost like you are
definitely not getting bumped this time
yeah
with all that exactly and I wonder if
that's the old they didn't run up a huge
tab over it ruby tuesday's right now I
wanna bring up something about because
obviously the way I met you was a lot of
not a not great rooms so um you you
going back to the earning stripes thing
I think one of the things that speaks
volumes about who you are is the fact
that you you roll with it like you never
you never get overly arrogant about the
fact like I don't belong here and you
don't tom but there's some people that
are either saying flat-out no I'm not
gonna do that one or the room and they
treat everybody like crap because they
believe that their love yeah place that
they are in that I love it exactly and
then just everybody else that's there is
like so are you just saying that we're
all not worthy of whatever element that
you're in but you've always kind of
taken everything every step along the
way no matter how much more successful
even a comedy always stayed the same
person where does that grounding come
from with you uh well a few things I
think it's some one you know I think I'm
funny you know and i know i'm a pretty
good writer and all of that stuff but
like it's just something about those
family members you know that a funnier
than you who have i oh you just feel
like like I would never say I'm a fraud
like I think I've earned things and all
that but you know you you you still have
that little bit of a like maybe I am a
fraud just because what if people figure
me out I know this one is I know people
funnier than me I know there's always
someone better so I think that that kind
of helps a lot and also I'm from a place
where like um when all the smoke clears
I know I'm seeing like a nice guy when
all the smoke clears it's like can you
beat my ass fighting that's all that
matters so like I can big-time you but
if I can't beat your ass what's the
point yeah so that's why I come from
like I think you have to respect
everyone as a man and that's where like
I Love New York comics but they get a
little weight with that like hierarchy
and just to believe in all comics but
you see where it's like oh don't talk to
that guy I don't talk to and I get in
trouble because sometimes I I forward
friendships maybe I shouldn't but I've
never been the type of guy that wanted
to it to be based on comedy only because
comedies only half the
like you're a man or a woman I'm a man
or a woman so we've gotta respect each
other just on that you know and so I
think that's why I don't have that that
attitude because um I think LA and in
comedy in general it's not a place where
people I think people underestimate
where it could go and I don't think it I
don't think it's common for people to
fight but I just always think it could
go there so that helps me just treat
everyone with respect you know well I
mean it's also I mean listen in any
given night there's a lot of waiting
around yeah there's a lot of just
sitting around you can get inside your
own head or now smartphones because
that's pretty much it so funny to see
comics now yeah like the upcoming come I
thought about Drake remember you see
Drake at radio stations looking at his
blackberry all those little freestyles
and yeah well not like behind like that
I we we I talked about this a couple
weeks ago the fact that um I see the
upcoming comics they a lot of their
faces when they're not on stage are
buried their smartphones like there's
there the education is not as the way it
was we only had our notebooks but that's
it we don't have anything else in all
their composure material yeah so you
look at that menu for facebook the whole
time I'm up next okay and use a Facebook
down for a sec go on stage and then get
back on Twitter better off and I tell
you if you're in a place where you are
the big dog all the time then you you
have to adjust that to you know you you
have to be in very you know various
situations where maybe you're the big
dog maybe a little dog and I think
that's where the best way the growth
comes in and I think I'm trying to
address that now I have been in too many
situations where I look around and like
I'm the most senior person you don't
want that to happen any you know that's
why it's good going to like the comedy
magic the county magic club you're in a
green room in like George Wallace is
there yeah Garry Shandling walks in okay
all right yeah you're like well I'm a
young buck yeah I can learn to do 10
push-ups where's your favorite place to
perform in town uh well you know I just
I think comedy magic is my favorite
place to hang out because of the green
room mate because of the food is great
and the guys like Garry Shandling or
adam sandler might stop last
up in there and now nastic semi-nice
that's like this web environment do you
still get excited when like people that
you are familiar with right around does
that still matter to yeah yeah well
skagit you don't get to see these guys
because you get to a point where like
like you know John and you guys are
doing the road right Brian and you don't
see guys that you came up with anymore
so now when you have when you go to like
a in town show you get to see them yeah
you get to connect with them so I like
that aspect of it a lot actually and uh
yeah like I like hanging with comics I
don't what I don't really like and I
don't really protest against I don't
like young comics and I'm we walk we
were all this at some point but I don't
I'd rather not be around young comics
who know nothing but think they know
everything that's that's not one formula
or they're always on or they always want
oh yeah that's a bit much SM and I think
that goes for I know older comics that
are like that to completely yeah and
you're just like oh you're gonna you're
still doing your set huh well we've been
out in the patio for a good hour and a
half now but I yeah this has been
entertaining and a great thing is that
we you still laugh on a patio which is a
different type of oh no yeah but you let
your laughing with your friends and
other people and you're sharing stories
that that really i mean you know when
you're in a field any kind of profession
it's like firemen can tell fireman
stories to other firemen because other
firemen will get it right i mean like
they'll understand whatever the
situation is whereas comics could have
those conversations that they can't go
home for Thanksgiving until their aunt
about or the cuz it's not gonna [ __ ]
understand they're just like what are
saying how come you're not in a movie
yet have you thought about getting on TV
and you're like oh my god I'll kill
everybody here yeah well my mom keeps
telling me to to disconnect with Tyler
Perry that's our home every time I saw
you know you need to get with tyler
perry is your mom series what no she's
so serious you don't need that at all
dude what do you mean but she has a
point he's got he's got long paper you
know built an empire but in a factory in
Atlanta I mean are any of those things
appealing to you it's like just your
like money is very good money fame is
good I was how long you been to a
synonym uh you know it's like man I
think it's 20 years okay yeah it's crazy
and when Jews the whole time like 15 6
maybe for teens on like that and when
did you start saying i wanna i want to
branch out I want to start writing I'm
gonna write scripts i wanna i want to
start doing even they even before i came
to LA but definitely when i came to LA
but because before i came to LA I I
always had a full time job so you know
but even when I was in Boston with my
full-time job I started taking acting
classes so I was trying to you know
dabble a little bit I remember I
remember that time being so hectic like
I remember having a girlfriend working
out taking acting classes the problem is
we didn't have the same gym and we had
different acting classes too so you
never saw her yeah we didn't see her and
it didn't work for a lot of reasons but
I remember like I never could just do a
load of laundry I always remember like I
would always like literally do my
laundry and it would be in the machine
or like all day while I was at work and
not mine not my own like it was it was a
group laundry like I was like when is
this [ __ ] [ __ ] who was close to
the dryer rock exactly so I would have
hated to live next to you it was a was a
hectic time but yeah started to branch
out Bobby Kelly actually the one who I
went with his acting teacher like that's
that was my first real like before that
I looked like in a phone book and I a
phone book you hear that kid would go
yeah i would go take acting classes
these guys I think they were a gay
couple two dudes and I would just go to
the house with other people and today
we're gonna act like we're not wearing
shirts all right I don't know if they're
alive in anymore but that's what started
and I wish I'd video of that because I'm
sure was awesome I was so bad like I i
even i felt like it was horrible it was
like i am not good at this so then i
went with a guy named Peter Kelly I know
through Bobby Kelly was a really good
actor Robert Kelly's are really good
actor they're not related early no not
at all you can I relate it but uh that
kind of so I was like planting the seeds
and you know I wish my only hope wish is
that I did even more back then but ok
but I realized that I wasn't I wasn't
lazy I just didn't have you know a lot
of time do you having done it so long
yes the road it's it become a grind or
do you still enjoy it are you
selective like how do you how is the
road to you now at this I've never found
out I've never burnt out because I don't
do the road quite as much as other
people and when you do it you don't get
blackout drunk you don't find spend a
weekend and all your paychecks on
cocaine and I don't do any of those
things and uh I I really just go to
Starbucks and work out so it's just I'm
just doing what I always do in a
different place okay he leaves his
laundry for the whole weekend so
wherever you're hiding Audrey sister and
I do a lot of international stuff which
is still fun for me okay going uh yeah
you weren't you just overseas with
schubert yeah no no that was a while ago
but I was just an Amsterdam oh cool ham
salmon and Rotterdam how was that ultram
it was great and you don't smoke pot huh
no gosh no but I feel like that's just
uh I mean it's not a wasted trip because
I'm sure you had fun and did a lot of
stuff besides go to the red light
district and get high but yeah well you
know my thing is uh uh you know a lot of
people listen to podcast now so I can't
really you know oh no yeah I uh that's
fine but uh but I've grown as a person
because like now I don't I don't judge a
place by if I if ya if I if I meet a
lady like 10 years ago if you said oh
how was Paris and I was like oh Paris is
great that only meant I met a girl in
Paris that's all right right it wasn't
like I went to the Louvre directly so I
experienced thing yeah how was Paris
Paris sucks that means i didn't i didn't
meet a girl in Paris Paris is a bunch of
dykes wait what now tomato on the other
hand Toledo also see Jesus got guys
Boise Idaho let me tell you what so i'm
i'm i'm out of that now so now if you
ask me how a places i'm judging it based
on the place actually and not what
happened we do you could travel the
world and experience things yeah exactly
outside of is there a woman over there
yeah I probably should talk to her but
that's nothing you should stop doing
that no but also I same time like that
that because that was never my style my
style because I couldn't work I couldn't
go meet people because I was too busy
like what we can get drunk in the town
square and like Ray hey I mean it just
every time have a square it's a square
like some of them were octagon 'ok
especially that's a european it's a lot
I've first my first night in uh in
London I fell asleep on the Piccadilly
Circus
found I just passed out on the staff
awesome they're like did you gotta go ya
impossible the humble stumbled off into
the night when I realize you could buy a
bottle of wine and sit out in public
with it and a restaurant had to uncork
it for you I was like well we're gonna
goes about they had to you have to I was
like I need a cork like just yellow in
England ah they they go so hard they
they goes they laugh at us because we
have a two-drink minimum them they can't
even comprehend it like what does that
even mean why would you do that why
would you have any drinks yeah why would
you if you're not going to have bailed
at more than two I have any yeah
translation we're alcoholics no
generation in London you don't have to
change too much for the audience's over
the right that's always a fear when you
know you got it sometimes change your
pacing but they they get it they get it
is it's more connected world's more
connected now right yes whatever they
definitely but London is not London is
pretty constant politan but England you
find yourself with two types of shows
yeah a really hip show where you don't
want you want your last per minute to be
lower actually because if you go for it
they'll be like oh this guy's trying too
hard you want to just be cool or really
shows that it we would think of as
hacking you gotta really just go for it
yeah they're like oh you're from the
town over I'll speak slower why you
gotta do all that and it's not like like
here we get in a plane we fly for hours
and we're like okay we're in Middle
America lads are different there you get
on a train you go an hour all completely
different they all live on farms and
home to have toothpaste where was the
hardest place overseas for you to a day
that you were like I gotta adapt a lot
here you do mostly expat stuff obviously
right we're mostly expats yeah um no I
think I've had fun everywhere okay have
fun I think parts of England can I
forget which towns what parts of England
can be tough it's because it keeps
changing your mindset because you assume
you're in one area and you're one place
if you will in general and you're like a
whole different could it be from plus if
there's a hen party which is a
bachelorette party we can get crazy no
different than over here yeah yeah yeah
the hen party I like that i'm gonna
start using my men party somebody welpen
parties in there like well I'm canceling
the show goodbye so tell me about this
you were talking before the show movie
yeah yeah this tell me so this is
something that you created is this is a
bit you were yes yes restoring it what
is so crazy you know in our business
like you had you write all these things
you do things and you never you never
know which one is gonna become a thing
right and so this has become a thing in
it the guy right within Koji Sakai uh we
he's super prolific he's actually has I
think for movies on netflix that she
wrote oh wow in his own good for her
he's a he's a machine he's like we're
writing a book now and uh like I write a
chapter he writes a chapter and like
literally I give him my chapter and like
as my hand is coming back he's got his
yeah it's it's and sanic Jesus right
right so he had an idea to produce a
movie and it's weird because I like the
story and everything but in all in all
honesty in a movie came out of we had
some restraints and from those
restraints we created a story that would
fit into that in terms so the restraint
was let's make a movie for 5 g's okay
like well how do you do that he's like
well he's not my friend did it has 11
location and you have to be off book for
the whole movie we ended up not doing
that but initially it was going to be
one location and I was going to just do
it like a play with three camera setups
the whole thing and I was down for that
but we ended up getting more than five
thousand dollars and and and you're
happy with that right I am was I
thinking not one I'm thinking you got a
better movie out of I would never hear
to me really upset they gave us a lot
moment that you didn't have to do this
on/off book three cameras stage was you
know honestly like I was looking forward
to it to have the story but it would
have been looking so incredibly hard
yeah so we end up getting more money
it's still eighty percent one location
right but we get out of that location a
few times and we have a trick we have
like a little document anything so we
get out of the room I'm locked in a room
it's called dying to kill okay it's a
play on I play a comedian who's pretty
happy at this point is life so a verge
of trying new material but too afraid to
afraid I in that gym and actually
when you meet me John is an audience
John is in the movie and he's the
heckler who's like had enough of my
hacky dick jokes and he heckles me and
that goes viral because we we get into a
fight we actually we actually took out
the inward you know that did you really
yeah yeah thank god dude he called me up
he's like hey man I don't know how you
feel about this but I wrote this movie
and we're gonna make it and I got a part
in it that you'd be perfect for and I
was like oh dude of course anything for
you send it over he sends me the script
it's like you're like in the first
senior the heckler and the first thing
this guy does is scream the n-word Adam
and I'm like I you wrote a part you
thought of me huh thanks buddy and the
whole time like there's other black
people there and I know we're acting and
I but it is just such an uncomfortable
word you know I mean so I was like I'm
like telling the audience and like look
guys just you know I'm friends with
Dwayne I know I look like I live on the
arm in rocket punch anybody who might be
brown-skinned but the thing is that's
not me so and I felt bad that because we
we put it in thinking uh because
basically he heck was me right and i'm
i'm at my low point creatively and when
he heckles me he gets the best of me i
attack him it goes viral and I was my
opportunity to to like take this moment
of attention and really come back with
better material and instead of doing
that I do the same hacky stuff so then a
crazy fan who we don't know might be
John might be someone kidnaps me I wake
up in a room chained and it's like you
have four chances to make me laugh or
each time someone else you love is gonna
get hurt or killed kind of like saw
meets soul meets meets misery meets the
king of comedy yes yeah so Anna anything
is when we we wanted to motivate me
jumping into the crowd that's why we had
John say the N word but when we got into
the when we started editing it we
realize well if he says the inward then
I'm I have justification oh yeah dude
everyone in the crowd should turn around
and start biting on me but what we want
is we want we don't want that we want
you John as the heckler to be right to
be one hundred percent right and that's
why I jump into the audience's because
ray he's right I'm I'm up here doing
dick jokes my character you know he's
hacky and you got it this guy's calling
me
out on it and [ __ ] for calling me out
and that's why I jump into the crowd so
you know I never really I don't know who
worked in Word and I don't think it was
me uh-oh I mean everything i do i found
out i improvised that and was like oh
was in the script they're like no dude
no that's nowhere in the script no no we
put it in but I don't think I don't
think I don't think I put it in but i'm
not sure like when i write things I try
to with people i try to pretty quickly
forget who wrote what okays it's like a
team effort yeah but yeah we decided we
didn't need it so but that's great i
know i like that you found that in the
Edit where you were like we want the guy
to be right and we want you to be yeah I
mean that to me that's great yeah and
plus I don't like a huge giant so uh yes
it's it's like we call it a comedy
horror but it's more like a comedy
suspense is your first full production
that you've done for yourself yeah yeah
it is an feature-length obviously July
yeah and we thought we were going to
come under time but we're good with the
time and now we're going out to
festivals and we'll see so it is edited
and pretty much done yeah is it get you
locked the score is being done now
that's a lot of work to make a movie
isn't it it is so much worse is just
writing it getting so much work acting
dad letting every Dell specially it's
more work if you don't have a lot of
money to write it because you just have
to think about everything and you're
doing more yeah if you had a shitload of
money you'd focus on acting and you'd
let somebody hire a production crew and
I wouldn't have to go what have you
brought a napkins and write exactly
exactly people's late and the team my
team they did they they're so great they
allowed me to sort of get to a point
where once we were started the camera
rolling I could I can only focus on
acting and and the amount of work after
the fact is crazy yes and that's the
boring work that's really a yes the
director rail I who is interesting which
you picked the director me and Koji it
was out our plan we put in a little
money we got more money I I said let's
do it with this guy rain he because I
did something else with rain he made me
look good so I'm like well ray make me
look good before let's have him do it
he'll make me look good again and was
it's it's it's just such a trusting
relationship because once you pick him
it's his movie so you're picking him
but it's his move he takes it over and
one hundred percent his movie and uh
he's done a great job and and I just
hope that I that I gave him what he
needed and I was you know well that's
that's where the trust is that you you
now have a director so he's directing
you so when he says okay we got it
you've got to assume or take that yeah
unless you're gonna be every shot I'm
gonna need to see that right we're doing
it because then the movies gonna take
ten years exactly so it's like sometimes
I've seen takes to myself where I'm like
dad why did they use that tape but I'm
like I can only do what I'm told I can
only act to the best of my ability
within a scene oh yeah and nothing beats
doing it so like even him telling me
this is your mindset do this do that
like there's some things I just wouldn't
been able to do that I could do right
now right because I've seen it right and
and and going through the process and
you know some things i wanna i went back
well i don't get those things back or
not but i but I you know I take that
learning take that learning forward you
know and so do you see yourself making a
lot more films yeah do you is that now
the process I hope so I hope so it's
weird it's like I was writing this other
movie and because I've only like
co-written movies I've never written a
movie except the first movie I ever
wrote in a class every other movie I've
written with someone so I was gonna
write this movie by myself and then just
busy with a bunch of stuff and I was
like who am i kidding so I called Koji
to bring him in but because I write with
people so it gets done the otherwise
i'll just keep putting it on a corona we
have someone else going here dude you
got those pages you like yeah I'll get
an exact line time to get them fine time
so koji took that you know saw the idea
that I had it's a zombie movie actually
the second thing and he was like well
let's make it a book and so now I'm we
almost we're almost finished the first
draft about our book that we want to
someday be a movie sure and what's great
is that co GI made one book already that
I was just a collection of essays that i
self-published koji has a book called
Romeo and Juliet vs zombies and so this
was right up his alley and he had to put
a publisher already so we kind of like I
like he tacked me in on his deal so now
you know we have a publisher it's not
like this great advance but
just to know that ok I give this book to
someone and it's gonna be and they have
to do some stuff yeah I don't have to do
everything with yeah yeah yeah you have
to write it I have to write it right and
hope that it sells but they'll help
exactly exactly so we're at so hopefully
that that might become a movie I have
some other we actually we actually have
a lot of stuff Kochi and I've written
for movies okay in a book okay then I
friend stuff with other people so yeah
definitely definitely want to you know
make more movies and so hopefully this
one gets some legs we sell it gets into
a festival you know it's been spent
super like it's crazy being busy in like
waiting for like planting those seeds
and waiting for the thing to grow yes
it's like takes forever man I mean I
what we uh must have been right before
my yeah because my surprise party was
spoiled because of uh of the movie like
I said it was well yeah I was that right
i was turning 40 and my then girlfriend
now fiance was planning a surprise party
for me and then I was I had a couple
scenes to do in your movie and she knew
that they were happening that week and
whatever and so she planned it for
friday night at eight-thirty because i
didn't have any shots that night and my
brother was flying in from New York with
his wife and I was all this whole thing
right so so thursday so like wednesday
comes up you know and she's like so
friday you have to do this thing she's
like there's no way to shoot it earlier
and I was like I don't know why you keep
asking about this I've agreed to do a
movie for a friend he needs me there on
these days I'm not gonna be like hey I
know I said I'd do this but [ __ ] you and
I need to shoot early I start getting
mad about it I'm like I'm like you got
to stop asking me because I'm not gonna
do what the [ __ ] is so great about
friday night and saturday night
meanwhile I'm set to like co-headline
the improv Jim Murphy so I'm like I'm
like we'll go out Saturday it'll be fine
you know what I mean and and then so uh
Wednesday she's like I got it I gotta
tell you your brother and his wife were
here we were gonna have a surprise party
I got down to your thing on friday night
and I was out in five minutes and I was
back home by seven-thirty and she wanted
to be at that thing by eight-thirty and
it all would have worked out perfectly
but she told me because I was convinced
that I'd be in long beach until like 11
so what he's saying is put the N word
back yet he's I
yeah moment ash I know as a racist it
was so funny cuz i cant rember who says
me see I told you have you out in time I
go in time you told me I'd be here to
like 1030-11 I was there and I can in my
head I was like I didn't say this on set
cuz I just didn't want to when I was
like you ruined my surprise party yeah
the next I was said it can only last
night was fancy I totally would have
worked out fine next night well you
don't know that [ __ ] and when you go to
a set you I mean look I've done
commercials where they're like hey you
have one line you say that one line
you're done at eight thirty in the
morning they keep you until seven thirty
at night you have done [ __ ] where
they're like hey get dressed come to set
20 minutes later I'm out of my wardrobe
and I'm back on this road going home
it's like it usually the Union spot it's
quick it's on time it's fast it moves
and you're done quickly and you make the
most amount of money right I knew you
know like here sit in this folding chair
will be with you in 15 hours have some
peanuts like oh my god why do I do this
can we have you back when the movie is
out oh absolutely absolutely yeah yeah
and actually pretty soon obviously we'll
let you know John we're going to have a
screening for cast and crew cool that I
want to i'll play you when we get off
i'll play the music that we have we only
have one song at the end it's just it
makes me laugh every time and I can't I
shouldn't go on record saying it but we
wanted to get another song we couldn't
get that song was too pricey so we had a
guy make another song it was kind of
like that song is it like who you're
gonna call spirit getters did it there's
a whole world out there people that's
what they do you know that's the trend
it's like yes it says it's like it's
like trans more first atlantic rim I
want this thing succeed I want to see
you continue to blow up big fan yeah
you're one of the good ones in town so
we want we want to see the rise at the
canyon yeah I my fingers crossed I wanna
know if I pull out there cuz some ppl my
nemesis nobody hey anybody listening to
show the job oh my god it's all I want
it I wanted to go to I wanted to
premiere I don't know what I wanted to
do what of the other producers want so
that's first and foremost but I
personally would like it to be at the LA
Film Festival yes we all live in LA dude
we made it in LA I think I think a
little things I think you're gonna the I
was in a movie that won best picture of
the LA
festo yeah so I mean you can do it right
why you like just because I mean I was
in most of the movie it's like just it's
good it's good it's a good or you don't
want to say which one I know it's
garbage garbage one oh yeah yeah yeah
you got a good shot right yeah I mean
garbage had a great movie West it was
just stop it was a garbage truck at the
premiere at the mann's chinese theater
look there was that the one you were
doing we needed the podcast you would
just got back from in Texas oh no that
was that hide-and-seek move okay that's
almost done too well yeah I did al it's
an independent movie about an adult hide
and seek or tag championship I know
that's right yeah yeah yeah yeah that's
pretty funny yeah I was like improv but
I don't know what we'll see everyone
says it's looking good so Dwayne working
people find you um Duane Perkins calm is
the website I got to have you on my
podcast to Brian movie night is the
podcast with Duane and TK they can find
that itunes anywhere kick know yet TK
Kelly and Dwayne Parker's com funny DP
is a twitter handle and I got some stuff
coming up in the next year in Canada
yeah Chicago natural cog will annoy so
we're at in the Illinois um it's like
begins with an M it's mundelein
mundelein when the line is that I'm a
seizure yeah anybody near mundelein next
year go check out the one great name for
february's 12 and 13 mundelein for like
a rock station I'm doing a show perfect
and then I'm doing some stuff we can the
underlying will be just how it sounds
just so you did that right yes you like
y'all get out there go oh yeah if I was
just discovering this place I call it
mundelein and what we're in Canada we
don't come the weekend before that fifth
and sixth of the Victoria Island which
is oh wow which is in a Vancouver and
then I've done a festival up there last
week in February and I think it's
catching her catching her Waterloo and
so with the the Waterloo festival the
catching the festival it sounds cold yes
blame for coal thanks for coming yeah
thnkx another snowman how we gonna share
it and best luck with dying to kill
thank you
thank you for listening to Hollywood
anonymous don't forget to follow us on
twitter at hollywood and nany that is
short for how we lookin onymous you can
also follow John individually at John
Huck and myself Brian or when at Brian
or went on Twitter as well both of us
can be found on facebook you can also
google us and contact us directly
Hollywood anonymous guys at gmail.com
thank you again so much for listening
and please don't forget to subscribe